hey guys dr. Burke here I'm doing this
webinar on how to basically understand
what symptoms mean and evaluating your
body symptoms based on what your body's
trying to tell you now this is
pre-recorded because the last webinar I
did it wasn't the slides weren't synced
to my video so basically I was over here
but you're like three slides behind so I
want to just create up a video that
works so you can follow along okay so so
I'm going to give you a lot of thumb
very cool if insights into what certain
symptoms mean because the problem in
healthcare is there's the management of
symptoms there's no real understanding
of what symptoms mean and what you
should do about them so we're going to
take it one step deeper look at the
cause-and-effect relationships so you
could kind of spot something and know
what's behind it and it's all related to
nutrition and we're going to look at
more visual things versus like
sensations like let's say fatigue or
that type of thing or depression we're
going to look at skin nails hair lips
like if you can look at either someone
or yourself and identify certain
problems I can I'm going to teach you
what's behind it okay so let's get
started let me just go right into the
slides okay
evaluating your nutritional deficiencies
now the first thing I'm going to cover
is I'm going to cover a little bit on
the nails so we have if you're looking
at either your nail or someone else's
nail a lot of things can go wrong with
the nail number one you can have
horizontal ridges that's a b1 deficiency
vitamin b1 deficiency so if you have
these ridges that go horizontal you need
b1 now vitamin b1 by the way is the
first B vitamin that was ever discovered
in the B family and then it goes vitamin
B two and three and four and five and
six
the first item that was ever discovered
was vitamin a and then B then C then D
and then he that was my dry sense of
humor but that's true that's how they
develop these or discover these vitamins
but b1 is the first B vitamin that they
discovered and basically it creates a
series of problems but the nail is a is
a good way to identify if you're
deficient in b1 all right so horizontal
ridges all right now there's a couple
other deficiencies that occur with b1
one is cyanosis and what is cyanosis
basically cyanosis means that your
circulation of your nail so let me just
show you a picture that you got these
white nail beds so if you ever look at
people and they just completely look way
too white that is a b1 deficiency
because vitamin b1 is involved in
circulation so it's kind of a white nail
also you can have an enlarged heart on
the right side of your heart yep the
left and right side of the heart the
right to the heart is influenced by me
b1 and so when you're deficient the
heart starts to get weaker and it starts
to enlarge or atrophy and it shows up as
something bigger on an x-ray like you'll
see in a large heart that's cardiomegaly
that's really a b1 deficiency so the B
vitamins are intimately involved in the
heart function the other thing is that
you'll have problems with the eye
muscles you ever see people will they
have like wandering eyes or they're
they're cross-eyed whatever that is a
weakness within the nerves to the eye
primarily the sixth cranial nerve and
that's also influenced by b1 okay be
when the efficiency can also cause edema
in your ankles so if you ever see people
like like let's say you press into the
ankle and it leaves a dent
that's a b1 deficiency
now a lot of times people like wonder
like how do I get a B vitamin deficiency
how do I get a b1 deficiency normally um
the history of this was involved with
people consuming too much polished rice
that's basically refined rice when they
take all the nutrition out of the whole
rice and they basically have this
refined white rice creating a b1
deficiency so and the same thing happens
with grains if you have this whole grain
with all this B these B vitamins and
then you strip it down you refine it you
turn into flour white flour and then
they bleach it you're going to create a
problem with b1 and the other B vitamins
and that's why they enriched divided
flour with synthetic vitamins you'll see
this flour is enriched okay but it's
really enriched with synthetic vitamins
it's not the real thing
so b1 and other B vitamins fishin C's
are created by consuming too much
refined foods specifically the grains
white rice flour as in bread pasta
cereal crackers biscuits while both
pancakes
even white sugar okay so that's how you
create a b1 deficiency and just from a
subjective symptom of b1 deficiency
you're going to have a lot of nervous
tension like you're gonna have worry
you're going to have anxiety you're
going to have a lot of this buildup of
stress low tolerance to stress that's it
b1 deficiency I mean how many people
have that so stress can deplete the B
vitamins and so can sugar and so can
refined foods okay okay let's talk about
brittle nails now brittle nails
typically people they go a lot of women
they get their nails done and they keep
putting surface shellac on it and nail
polish and they try to strengthen the
nails and they do all these things to
try to fix the nail but if I was doing
now I could actually identify brittle
very easily by determining the
nutritional deficiency fixing that and
helping the person correct the real
problem versus just filing it down but
brittle nails is usually a another B
vitamin deficiency specifically biotin
which has another name for vitamin H but
biotin will Craig brittle nails because
biotin is involved with the
strengthening of proteins amino acids in
collagen that's why it's really good for
hair but if you take too much of biotin
over time it can create a problem with
causing deficiencies of other vitamins
and people can get acne so so I'd like
to look at the whole picture and not
just try to fix a vitamin but look find
out why you're deficient in a certain
vitamin you know it has to do with your
diet now how do you become deficient in
biotin well several ways number one you
can eat a lot of raw egg whites okay
like when people put raw eggs in their
shakes and things that can create a B a
biotin deficiency another way would be
to you either find foods another way
which is connected with your gut see
certain friendly bacteria in your gut
make biotin so a lot of people that are
deficient in vitamin have an imbalance
in their digestive system so they need a
good probiotic to build up that biotin
okay so those those are some of the
things that that can happen
another thing with biotin deficiency
would be the little the cuticle you get
all these peeling on your cuticle that's
a biotin deficiency and one good source
of biotin is nutritional yeast okay you
can get it from Amazon I would
personally recommend going to Amazon and
getting the non fortified nutritional
yeast which basically is without
synthetics a lot of times nutritional
yeast they enrich you with synthetics
which is it is a problem but it's a
minor problem because naturally a
nutritional yeast has a lot of natural B
vitamins so it's not just all synthetic
so it's less of a problem if you have a
combination but I mean if you're going
to get it from Amazon might as well get
the the non fortified 100% natural B
vitamins now why don't they sell natural
B vitamins in a pill it's very rare to
find it it's very expensive for example
if you they were to make biotin in a
pill in a supplement it's roughly about
eight hundred dollars a kilogram which
is 2.2 pounds
I think it's 2.5 or 2.2 pounds that's
eight hundred dollars right if you would
buy it synthetically it's like maybe
nine or ten dollars per kilogram so all
these vitamin D fashion companies are
not giving you the natural version
they're giving you a synthetic which
come with problems down the road if you
take too much of it or too long a period
of time I'm ok with taking synthetic
vitamins if they're for a detox but any
other reason I don't like them so how do
you know if it's natural or not you have
to look at the source of where they get
the vitamin and anything that's like
over like if it says like six thousand
percent times the normal value or even a
thousand times normal in the back of
label you know it's synthetic
because you can't put that much natural
vitamin in a pill so that's why you're
seeing all these synthetic vitamins
nowadays but anyway biotin deficiency
can create a lot of problems of your
nails hair and definitely the cuticle
and this is it keeps the nail nail shop
in business alright let's go on the next
one vitamin B
deficiency it creates a redness around
the nose the cheeks and even the top of
the forehead this is a b6 deficiency and
call it rosacea whatever you can call it
psoriasis it's just a redness around
that the nose area and on the nose as
well so it's interesting the B vitamins
create a lot of skin problems and a lot
of digestive problems a lot of hair and
nail problems so you'll see as we go
along so that's the b6 deficiency again
where do you get b6
b6 is actually easy to get from most
foods
it's an eggs it's in vegetables it's in
a lot of different foods but it's
usually the foods that are like junk
food that pulls it out like refined
carbohydrates breads pasta cereal
crackers biscuits waffles pancakes
that's what's pulling it out and yes it
could be an allergy to gluten and things
like that but um I mean someone people
are living on refined foods this is
what's causing it okay a zinc deficiency
will create those little white little
specks on the nail but if you the nail
grows every six months so if you see a
white speck let's say in the middle of
the nail that's like three months ago
you created that white speck now if
we're looking at the nail right here
it's probably if we divide this now by
six it's probably like maybe two months
twenty percent of the nail two months
ago
there's a zinc deficiency that was
created now what causes a zinc
deficiency eating a lot of carbon
carbohydrate like in sugar so we can
pretty much tell about a month about two
months ago they had a birthday party and
they ate the whole cake by this white
speck on their nail so they ate a lot of
carbohydrate and so and I do this people
and they've kind of freaked out like how
did you know that
well because I'm I'm actually reading
and interpreting what your body is
trying to tell me I understand the
language and this is what we're trying
to do in as webinars to teach you how to
read your body okay that's the zinc
deficiency but it's really a sugar
deficiency the trace minerals which is
like zinc which basically trace minerals
are minerals needed in smaller amounts
um like selenium iodine zinc [ __ ]
things like that versus the bigger
minerals like calcium magnesium sodium
potassium needing needed in larger
amounts but we need the small trace
metals most people that I run into our
deficient in trace minerals because the
trace minerals are no longer in the
soils um unless you get food from places
that have volcanic soils I was in
Grenada which is an island which is
basically they grow this chocolate this
cocoa bean and they have the soils are
so rich with these volcanics these
minerals from the volcano that it gives
incredible flavor to the cocoa bean and
Switzerland and Belgium get their
chocolate from the island or they get it
from Africa the same deal in Africa they
have the volcanic ash and the soil is
rich and it gives the flavor of the food
and I tell you I believe that a lot of
people's that can live in the areas
where they had volcanic ash in the soils
they they don't seem to gain weight that
much even if they eat you know whatever
they eat they also have good bone
structure they don't have a lot of
problems with their dental structure so
it's hard to find these trace metals
nowadays but that's a zinc deficiency
thyroid thyroid problem will create
vertical ridges up and down so that's a
classic symptom vertical we just
the thyroid will also create a lot of
other things like loss of collagen in
the back of the arm
so will the adrenal and also it creates
problems with hair loss and it will
create issues with bags with the eyes
and a loss of the eyebrow on the outer
part so these are just little things
that you can look at if you're trying to
identify yourself and again I like to
look at the whole body and not just take
one little symptoms that you have this
deficiency I look at all the symptoms
and for those of you that as we go
through this want to know like what
foods are high in certain nutrients I'm
going to share a download little button
link below that you can download all
these deficiencies like um basically
where to get zinc what foods are high in
vitamin A etc so give you that data when
we're done okay here's a condition
inflammation in the mouth and the lips
do little ulcers on the lip you'll see
them or skin rashes and things like that
and then there's another condition which
is inflammation in the corner or angles
of someone's mouth called angular
chalasis or Chile's and that and you see
that a lot in kids or even in adults
where you have this little cracking in
the corners of the mouth this is the
vitamin b2 deficiency riboflavin um
personally I used to have this growing
up course I lived at refined foods so
definitely it's a b2 deficiency again
where do you get b2 it's in nutritional
yeast it's in and it's basically what
you have to do to avoid having a
deficiency of it by avoiding the sugars
and the refined carbohydrates and all
that so let's go into the next one b3
deficiency vitamin b3 deficiency it's
called pellagra now what is that it
there's a condition called glove and
stocking lesions where you have this
severe scaly red irritated skin on
and the feet that's a very severe b3
deficiency okay so you ever see it
that's what it means
but look what causes pellagra consuming
too much corn or consuming too much
alcohol because corn is not very
nutrient dense and that can create a
deficiency especially the corn that
people eat nowadays it's GMO it's the
corn syrup and all that crap okay
b2 deficiency riboflavin here's another
one a bloodshot eyes
that's a b2 deficiency jaundice now what
is jaundice jaundice is a backup of the
liver into the bloodstream where you
have a liver problem and you're going to
your whites of your eyes are going to LA
you're skin will be tainted yellow this
is a congested gallbladder or a
congested liver now if someone consumes
let's say they consume a lot of carrot
juice for example they will turn yellow
eventually or kind of an orange
that's not jaundice that's just the
pigment that's coming out that's its
Inanna it's not a problem it's not a
serious problem it just means that you
got you're doing too much carrot juice
and again carrot juice is just way too
much sugar we don't want to do that I
used to do a lot of characters I thought
it was good for me but it basically
started creating blood sugar problems
cuz there's so much concentration sugar
even though there's vitamins in it it's
still very very unhealthy okay so I'm
eating the whole carrot is is better
okay let me just go back to these slides
ok jaundice vitamin A deficiency now
vitamin A um is almost like a hormone
just like vitamin D it's a fat type of
vitamin it can go into the DNA of your
cells it can determine what your what
cells turn into like if there's a
problem
with vitamin A you have this weird
growth on your skin on the eye and you
can even have like a white little shell
or pigment right over your the black
part of your eye the iris so you can
also have these little growths on your
on your the whites of the eye as well so
it doesn't have to be right over the eye
could be on the side of the inside of
the outside that's about an innate
efficiency so anything to do with
vitamin A without skin or acne I always
go to buy diamond a but what foods are
high in vitamin A you say vegetables yes
it's true but all vegetables like
specially like kale have tremendous
amount of minute amounts like even with
spinach it's like 30,000 in I use of
vitamin A but that's all a pre vitamin A
it's not the actual active form of
retinol which is vitamin A that you can
use so it has to be converted into the
body and with some people they can't
convert it that well some people they
can but an average you might convert 4%
so where do you get your vitamin A from
the fats from the butter from the oils
from the column oil but if your
gallbladder and your liver is congested
you don't have the bile to break down
the vitamin A so so a lot of vitamin A
deficiency has come from a problem with
the liver of the gallbladder and if you
especially like you don't have the
gallbladder they become deficient in
vitamin A so these are just kind of side
notes so you might take bio may and not
see any change but I've noticed that
when people start eating healthier and
they clean out the liver or they support
the gallbladder all us and their skin
gets really good and their acne goes
away that is because you're absorbing
more about it maybe because you're
getting more bile output file is kind of
like the detergent and salt dissolves
the grease okay one of the classic
symptoms of vitamin A deficiency has
night vision issues you can't see at
night
everything comes blurry especially if
there's bright oncoming traffic lights
you'll you have a
with them that's the vitamin A
deficiency now as you age and the liver
gets more congested you can even lose
your just your vision you notice like
when you get in your forties fifties
like your vision is just so bad that
could be about emanate efficiency as
well but it's really a liver problem
okay okay next slide here's another
vitamin A deficiency it's kind of like
these little fever like by some chicken
look at the skin you see those little
follicles your little red little bumps
on the skin that and if you have that
like on your skin or behind the arm
that's a vitamin A deficiency I'm
telling you anything well with skin is
usually connected vitamin A so so far we
have three main deficiencies that most
people have a problem with that involve
the skin the hair the nails so which is
basically like protein you have the fats
all the vitamins the trace minerals and
the B vitamins those are the ones that
always show deficient in a lot of people
here's another B 2 B 3 deficiency
cracked corners of your heel like your
heels get really really dry that's a b2
b3 deficiency so if you put lotion on
that thing you're just treating the
symptom but it's interesting you go to
medical doctor you go to the
dermatologist which they have in every
corner in Florida I mean I went down
there I'm like wow they have so many
dermatologists and all they're doing is
they're giving you cortisone creams for
everything for skin problems doing
biopsies but they're not even getting
close to the root problem at all
alopecia okay what is that Ella pichia
is a biotin deficiency could be adrenal
problems but it's using a biotin
deficiency so you start getting these
spots of loss of hair but again if your
diet is fairly good it's probably coming
from your gut you have some digestive
maybe you just a problem maybe you had
it semantic biotics maybe you had some
leaky gut issues that could be coming
from
something in the past and you've never
got your digestion fixed so you got to
look at the whole whole picture here
just taking biotin is not the answer the
answer is getting your whole diet
corrected
biotin is also good for male pattern
baldness and also thinning hair let's
just touch on male pattern baldness in
females and men a lot of times they'll
say that's an energy and efficiency but
in reality if that was true why do men
have male pattern baldness well as they
age when at the same time they're
antigens their testosterone is
decreasing how can that be
I mean if antigens are testosterone
excessive amounts of estrogen or herbs
or excessive amounts of testosterone
cause now part of all this doesn't make
sense because it decreases with age well
what happens really it's an estrogen
excess that's converted to a powerful
estrogen called DHT so it's an estrogen
problem men and women it's just
converted so if you have the right ratio
to estrogen to testosterone you won't
have this problem so and this is a side
note if you have a problem with this or
you're getting a loss of hair and then
in the head or in a male body you're
getting prostate problems a really good
remedy to help kind of correct the
ratios of estrogen to testosterone is
something called stinging nettle root so
get some of that that's really good for
a prostate and also male pattern
baldness and also if you're just losing
hair and you're female of course your
own prostate go ahead and take it as
well okay iodine deficiency creates an
enlarged thyroid in your neck or Gore's
or nodules in the thyroid see here's how
if you're all these little cysts on the
thyroid on the breast on the ovaries
come from excessive estrogen but see
iodine protects the excess of estrogen
so it competes with estrogen so if
you're deficient iodine estrogen can
create a lot of damage to your your body
especially a female body so if you have
good amount of iodine in the diet from
seek help which I recommend get the
organic kind because if you just get
regular you know seek help from the
store it might be contaminated with
arsenic you want to get something from
Iceland or something that's organic
that's really healthy but here's the
point I then and will actually decrease
estrogen and it actually is a good
cancer preventer and it actually handles
cysts nodules of the thyroid of the
breast fibrocystic breast of the ovary
very very important the tongue if it's a
red tongue that's a b2 deficiency if
it's a glossy red tongue that's a b12
deficiency a white tongue is a yeast
overgrowth okay so that's a yeast and
balance that's a gut problem fissures in
the tongue it's a b12 deficiency it can
happen like down the center on the sides
these well be vitamin deficiencies now
you see the outer part of the eye the
eyebrow it's like there's no hair there
that is a thyroid problem and you know
what's interesting about the thyroid is
the thyroid blocks the absorption of
nutrients in the body so really it's a
nutrient deficiency but the thyroid can
create the nutritional deficiency so
again you know you need to understand
how the whole body works now this is a
real common thing I see a lot of people
you see like a pink toothbrush like you
get bleeding gums or or red swollen gums
they call it gingivitis that's about it
and C deficiency it's a form of scurvy
because vitamin C strengthens the
capillary beds so anything like micro
hemorrhaging up like those varicose
veins spider veins the little red cheeks
anything with vascular
things like that that's about in-situ
pitch vitamin C deficiency but what's
happening at the cellular level is they
even in your arteries you're getting
little lesions and bleeding in the
arteries and that's when you have the
accumulation of cholesterol as a
band-aid and calcium has abandoned in
the arteries and then you get a clogged
artery so these people that have
gingivitis really have they're
developing problems in the vascular
system as well but if you have brush
your teeth and you get bleeding that's
about NC deficiency do not take the
synthetic vitamin C get it from the food
concentrated food I use the wheatgrass
juice powder myself but you can get it
from just a lot of vegetables as well
versus one juice has no vitamin C
because it's pasteurized but they put
some synthetic in there so don't take
the synthetic now if you have too much
fluoride which a lot of times in the
water supply they use too much flora
that can create that discoloration in
the tooth and that creates an imbalance
in calcium metabolism so I mean it's
like that everyone's like so Pro
fluoride but it's very toxic to your
body actually if you've been follow me
you know about the body types if you
look on if you someone has a heavier
hips
that's an ovary type if they have a
health side belly that's adrenal type if
they're weight all over that's a thyroid
if it's more of a protruding belly
that's a liver problem okay so you can
look on the outside of the body and
determine what's going on the inside it
chief foot on the bottom of the foot
that is a liver problem it's a liver
issue just wanna let you know um
neuromas what's an aroma it's a little
nerve bundle on the bottom of the foot
that can be very painful to do search
around it that's a virus viruses come
out of remission when your dreams are
weak you can't kill a virus because a
virus is not alive mix blindness so
viruses are very fascinating they
basically maybe get activated and to get
inactivated
they get activated by your own tissues
when you become tired stressed out
burnt out get older the viruses come out
of remission and they create all sorts
of damage like shingles and herpes and
all these other issues but when you're
healthy they go back into remission but
the adrenals control if it's going out
or in so you can't kill a virus or do
your only solution is to get healthy but
it's interesting because viruses usually
come out when you go through stress
they're activated okay now um so here's
what I'm going to recommend I developed
I spent a lot of time creating an
advanced evaluation questionnaire it's
kind of a free test someone can go on
and this is the URL the address online
that you can go to that you can take
this lengthy evaluation and I'll explain
exactly what the heck this thing is I
created this quiz awhile ago and it has
104 questions it has every single
symptom you could possibly imagine and
what I did in my spare time is I took
every single symptom and I evaluated all
of the potential causes of that one
symptom then what I did is I I created
logic so when you were to fill out this
quiz it associates with other symptoms
so it looks at other symptoms that you
have and all those potential causes to
find the most like likely cause the
number one cause of all of your symptoms
okay so that's it actually thinks so
it's on automatic pilot so you don't
need a practitioner to tell you what it
is so so what I did is I created this
quiz and then I kind of gave I wanted to
not just evaluate and tell you what your
problem is but to help you understand
and interpret what that means and and so
you can have a greater deeper background
of the symptom and what you should be
eating
and what remedies would be good for you
both additional remedies like a pelvis
door or just general remedies things
like that to actually now just treat
symptoms but we want to treat the cause
of the symptom and correct it okay so
it's kind of like a training program as
well as an evaluation software okay
then what I did is I created all the
potential to fish causes of problems
like low vitamin b1 low fat soluble
vitamins low B to low potassium and I
created all the symptoms that could
occur from those causes so when you take
this quiz it died sex everything and
comes up with a really cool freakin
report that you will love okay so and
then I have all these different remedies
that you can use to actually correct it
so um here's what I recommend that you
do take the quiz you go to dr. Berg com4
slash evaluation take the quiz and it's
not a short quiz it's a long quiz it's
104 questions but it's awesome because
it'll actually dissect everything for
those people that are under my
membership site they can take it every
month but I'm just letting you two take
it as a one-shot deal for free normally
I'll charge for it because one of my
health coaches will contact you just
kind of review it and then send you the
report
okay so just help you understand it and
then you can go through it at your
leisure and just start to learn from it
okay so it's a I think it's a very cool
evaluation and I'm gonna allow you to
take you know one evaluation and that is
basically your next step and let me just
kind of put this up on the screen to
you'd go to dr. Berg comm forward slash
evaluation and um you're basically going
to just fill out the thing and it might
take us a day or two to get back to you
because we're going to analyze it look
at it and then contact you walk you
through it
you know take a couple minutes and then
what we'll do is we'll send you the
report and you'll have a really cool
assessment of what's going on to your
whole body and the underlying deeper
root problem that that that you need to
focus on because you know my whole thing
is this stop treating symptoms let's
treat the cause of it let's let's go
deeper your results are dependent on
getting the real problem and so if
people get results um then they're they
can actually resolve a problem and
there's nothing worse and I see this all
the time with people basically treating
symptoms and they keep treating symptoms
they never get to the root of it and
they keep going and keep going and they
just get frustrated so to go the doctor
of this specialist so this quiz is about
an advanced evaluation technology
evaluation means finding a real cause
understanding what the body's trying to
tell you like like even if you have pain
your body's trying to tell you don't
move right if you pain when you eat
something what does your body trying to
tell you avoid that food so this is all
about trying to understand what the
language of the body is in interpreting
symptoms okay so anyway that's the quiz
and I wanted to share just some insights
on that with going through the different
assessments but now you'll be able to
look at someone um three feet away and
kind of spot what they're deficient in
which is good and bad because you're
gonna probably now want to evaluate
everyone you know just don't much my
name I can just see you now like do you
know how to be to deficiency yeah maybe
people might not accept that but this is
good for friends and family so I hope
you enjoyed this webinar I hope you
learned something and your next step is
to take the evaluation and I appreciate
your attention thus far you made it this
far and I will see you in the upcoming
videos so thank you very much and I will
see you soon